in the division from whence goff came
the nfc west the seahawks
trying to adjust their offense on the
fly receiver dk metcalf
says the new offense under shane waldron
is more intricate
my first thought when i saw that was
well it can't be any less intricate than
it was
i think that's a fair way to say it
right like how many times did we have
that conversation last year
of where seattle lack of movement
lack of different formations personnel
sets
you know how many times did i say to you
during like a wednesday where we've
i've watched film with the seattle game
and go they waste plays
they run plays where it's like yeah they
called it the huddle the defense is in
the perfect defense
to stop that play and they still just
run it and go
let's just see if we can make it happen
so i think like what metcalf is saying
with more intricate is
there's more options there's more
adjusting on the fly
i'm sure with plays you know in the
huddle
at the line of scrimmage and i bet you
there's alpha also what he means by
intricate more rules to like
hey you run this route but if the
coverage does this or this guy does that
we'd like you to adjust it to this or
that that's going to be the genius
because of course it's mcveigh
and that's where the system's from
mcveigh shanahan it's well thought out
there's going to be some rules and i
think that's where
it can be beneficial for for seattle on
that side of the ball
and if they want to have any hope
whatsoever of keeping russell wilson in
the fold
for more than the next one two or three
years
you got to give him a little more power
you got to give him a little more
freedom you got to you got to let him
have a seat at the table yeah a
meaningful seat at the table not just a
perfunctory okay yeah we
he's at the meeting but we don't pay
attention to him he's got to be part and
parcel of what they're doing or
he won't be there he and and and
seahawks fans even after everything
that's happened this year are still
in denial and the idea that it's more
likely than not he's not going to be
there
yeah to me it's like this is their last
chance
to show him that they really value him
the way the chiefs value patrick mahomes
yeah to me it's like more like what is
it gonna take to keep russell wilson
there
like what what is it mike like what do
you think i mean of course we know they
gotta win games and do that
but i would think there has to be yeah a
certain way the offense is played
the way the game looks his statistics
are going to
to me play play a part of this there's
no doubt about it
you know so you know i did that to me is
just
what it what is it i mean the numbers
are going to look good
no matter what offense russell wilson is
is is in
he's freaking awesome all right he's
really good and the
the nfl is made for quarterback stats
right now but like
yeah i just to me like when you think
about it like you know what do you think
what what is it
is it just got to be wide open and it's
just more fun and more around him
i don't know it's got to run through him
yeah
and i remember last year when we did
your top 40 countdown we had
mahomes and wilson in close proximity
and
it was the first time i noticed that at
least when you look at the highlights
and highlights can be deceiving because
they're the best
you know some guys have a greater
concentration of their plays that are on
the side of consideration for the
highlight reel and i think mahomes has
more highlight reel plays overall than
russell wilson but
russell has an efficiency and a
suddenness to his movements that you
don't really appreciate
the what he can do yeah he moves so fast
he and he doesn't he doesn't have that
hair on fire dynamic that patrick
mahomes has when he's running around
left and right and trying to buy time
and make something happen he just goes
and does it wilson does
yeah and you know remember how the
season began it was let russ cook and it
was great and oh
he's never had did you know he's never
had a single mvp vote this year he's
going to get all of them
and then the wheels came off and i still
don't fully understand why the wheels
came off
but they weren't able to put the wheels
back on effectively yeah
and uh they were one and done in the
playoffs and you know this this shane
waldron arrival this is all about
trying to and trying to find the right
way to keep russ happy but at the same
time you got to keep pete carroll happy
yeah
pete carroll's old bud grant protege
that doesn't want all his fancy stuff he
wants to go play defense and run the
football
i think they got a chance i think to
maybe appeal to both sides here with
like shane waldron and maybe get both
accomplished to where it's like yeah
we're still controlling the game we're
efficient on the offensive side of the
ball we don't abandon the run
but we got a little bit more of a high
octane attack i think pete carroll can
get behind that and then maybe russell
wilson will be able to get behind that
too
but like you know you you we understand
we do we know why that they
faltered we do we've said it like we got
to give ourselves credit here and listen
they got rid of the offensive
coordinator they're telling us too
we know it got right around that week
nine or ten part
of the season where teams start to get
the breakdowns down and they go
wait we got eight or nine games of when
they do this route
the other guy runs this route when dk
metcalf lines up here
these are the three plays they run it
became too predictable
it'd be and it would be hard for any of
any quarterback to have been successful
with with some of those game plans that
i saw last year in that offense so
i think that's why i scout thyself yeah
it's exactly right i mean we had those
conversations a lot i feel like towards
the end of the year about their offense
yeah i mean you've got to stay ahead of
the curve of your own predictability
that is so
critical as you're studying the film of
your opponents you have to have people
in the building who are studying your
own film
and coming up with the ways they would
attack you and where are the weaknesses
where are tendencies where are tells
how will others perceive what we're
doing
and that's going to be the challenges
here for the seahawks if they have
success
early and they've got the manpower to do
it
can they sustain it yeah that's where
shane waldron's job is going to become
critical hi i'm mike tarico and thanks
for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports